the home secretary has announced extra
measures to deal with protests following
the disruption caused by the insulate
britain group now we've discussed
protest tactics here more than once but
what about the protesters cause how
would we insulate britain and how much
would it cost so donica to you first of
all before we drill into the cost tell
me why you think it's important for the
environment for us to all insulate our
houses
sure around 15 of the uk's carbon
emissions comes from heating and so
therefore it's crucial that we tackle
the emissions from britain's homes which
are among the worst insulated in the in
the in europe
so it's essential we if we actually
insulate our homes we cut
the cost of running them and the
admissions from them by over a third so
it's crucial to put this on top of the
agenda for the government
so essentially we don't need to turn the
heating up so much if we're well
insulated in our homes it helps bring
down the emissions it's essentially what
you're saying is it absolutely the the
amount it would cost to run and heat
your home would be at least a third if
not more if our homes were properly
insulated
it's not just carbon emissions though of
course it it also is the huge issue of
excess winter debts around 8 000
pensioners a year are dying from
actually living in cold homes across
britain
nearly 5 million people in britain are
living with fuel poverty having to try
and make the choice between food and
heat in their homes so it's just a
no-brainer for us to be insulating our
homes across britain okay and this is
what the leader of the opposition vicky
has said about it he said we have the
least energy efficient housing in europe
so if we're going to do something about
it vicky how much would it cost
well the things that you need to do of
course when you are trying to insulate
the home particularly one which was
built some time ago is to deal with all
sorts of different parts of the house
that need
insulating so you have loft insulation
you have cavity wall insulation you have
floor insulation
you have you know drought excluders you
can do all sorts of things and of course
each of those costs and costs quite a
lot and given that we have loads of old
homes
the average cost for the older homes is
considerably higher than say building a
new house or those that perhaps have
been built you know in the last couple
of decades so if you add it all up and
you look at a an old house might cost to
do all these things that i just
mentioned including of course improving
the heating itself so converting from
gas boilers to other
ways of heating your home which are more
efficient could be up to 28
000 30 000 pounds it could be a bit less
for the uh ones that were built more
recently so if you multiply that we have
29 million homes
in the uk roughly okay so quite a lot of
them need to be insulated we're talking
about hundreds of billions and that's
the real issue where is the money going
to come from well
you're shaking your head there donna but
it's a lot of money that needs to be
found how are we going to pay for this
yeah just multiplying it by 26 million
is nonsense um 50 of uk houses already
have their walls insulated we need to
insulate the other 50
the estimate is that we need to spend 6
billion a year to 2035 that comes out as
75 billion we could actually fund that
easily
by actually switching the investment
from hs2 which is just going to cut an
hour for rich people traveling by train
to edinburgh to investing in people's
homes for poor people to lower their
bills and make them warm and cutter
carbon emissions
the long promised heat and buildings
bill is due to be announced by the
government so we may get more details on
what their plans are but quickly come
back at donica there he he disagrees
with your figures very briefly
you know i mean
he may be right in terms of what has
happened so far and what still is needed
to be done but i mean the the numbers
are still where we said hundreds of
millions billions i'm sorry in any case
it needs to be spent but um but the
issue is
maybe maybe whatever there are and loads
of different calculations of what is
actually required is still a lot of
money i don't agree that we're going to
have to think about how
uh that can be spent whether we should
be switching from something else and
whether in fact taxes need to be
increased but also i think there has to
be a lot of support for the individual
homeowner what we've seen is the moment
cheap options disappear the homeowner
just doesn't do the loft installations
that i need they just move out of even
bothering to do any of those uh taking
any of those measures that would save
quite a lot interesting interesting
stuff and i'm sure we'll talk a lot more
about this in the weeks ahead
you